l'histoire de l'informatique c'est aussi
c'est aussi une révolution informatique
et aujourd'hui on la vit pleinement mais
elle a démarré
finalement il ya assez longtemps parce
que l'informatique c'est tout le sujet
autour de l'information et c'est un
sujet qui intéresse l'humanité depuis
très longtemps
bon ça a commencé avec le boulier au
début c'était toujours des nombres c'est
bien on est ado filmé départ l'écriture
a été et est comptable au départ dont il
y avait le boulier puis après petit à
petit on a cherché à mécaniser tout ça
donc j'ai fait un saut dans le temps
mais il ya une période qui est je pense
assez fascinante qui était à peu près au
xviiie siècle où les gens se seront
commencé à s'intéresser à des automates
alors là vous avez le canard de
vaucanson on voit pas forcément très
bien mais en oui à un canard et en
dessous il ya des routes de tambours qui
permettent de faire bouger ce canard et
alors ça amuse et énormément les rois et
les princes et donc monsieur vaucanson
est devenu très connu et il a intéressé
beaucoup de gens parce qu'il ya des gens
qui sont dit tiens on peut appliquer sa
bombe dans les salons mais également
pour faire des machines à tisser et donc
là vous avez quelque part une des
premières machines programmables enfin
les rangs où vous avez une de parmi les
deux premières machines programmables
donc une avec une machine à tisser où on
passait on passait des cartes qui
permettait de faire des motifs
donc c'était une machine programmables
et ça ça va intéresser une autre
personne derrière qui connaissait donc
beau quand son qui connaissait donc
vaucanson et qui connaissait aussi le
métier jacquard un pur pour tisser c'est
monsieur baba qui lui s'est dit tiens je
vais faire une machine à calculer
programmables et donc cesser de
l'orfèvre ses machines ses de
l'orfèvrerie c'est d'une précision assez
incroyable et donc ses premières
machines informatiques étaient très très
précises après il y en a une autre qui
est assez connue vous avez peut-être
entendu parler parce que je crois qu'il
est un film qui est passé récemment
alors là c'est la machine des allemands
1 c'est la machine enigma alors pareil
c'est une machine alors là on est passé
à l'électro mécanique
avant c'était plutôt mécanique et après
c'est devenu électromécanique et après
il ya un personnage que vous connaissez
certainement dont vous avez entendu
parler
c'est là qu'il ya eu la rupture c'est
alan turing qui lui un peu comme carnot
à créer
la machine de turing paraît une machine
qui n'existe pas mais une machine
théorie qui permet de poser toutes les
théories de l'informatique moderne et
l'appareil ça ça a déclenché une
accélération que l'on vit tous
aujourd'hui donc maintenant après vous
avez eu à l'invention des transistors
etc qui font que maintenant on a des
ordinateurs tous dans notre poche
alors à quoi ça sert l'informatique
parce que bon les moissonneuses
batteuses tout ça on voit bien
l'informatique aujourd'hui il ya une
explosion autour du calcul informatique
et de tout ce qu'on peut faire avec et
ça c'est important que vous vous ayez en
tête pourquoi les ordinateurs vont se
vont se multiplier dans les années à
venir
aujourd'hui il ya des sujets comme le
réchauffement climatique qui sont des
sujets sur lesquels il ya beaucoup de
recherches ont fait beaucoup de
simulation auto autour de tout ça c'est
vrai aussi autour du climat de la météo
de la médecine mon il ya aussi la
finance alors pour la petite histoire
moi j'ai travaillé pendant sept ans en
finance de marché en informatique sur ce
sujet là et il consomme énormément de
puissance de calcul alors a complètement
à l'opposé des financiers vous avez les
gens qui font des dessins animés
donc les dessins animés vous pouvez
aller voir les dessins animés de pixar
ou de dreamworks consomme énormément de
puissance de calcul et puis à des
nouveaux domaines qui émerge comme les
biotech ou aujourd'hui on peut faire par
la simulation numérique des choses qu'on
ne pouvait faire que par l'expérience
avant et on arrive comme on commence à
réussir à simuler des protéines de plus
en plus grosse et donc ça permet de
simuler les médicaments qui seraient
utiles dans tel ou tel
telle maladie après bon il ya plein
d'autres domaines d'application et ça ne
fait que ça ne fait que grossir alors
bien sûr vous avez certainement tous
entendu parler de la loi de moore qui
dit que votre ordinateur est de plus en
plus performants chaque année vous avez
tous constaté que c'était pas toujours
le cas mais c'est un fait effectivement
les ordinateurs chaque année consomment
de moins en moins d'énergie pour faire
la même quantité d'opérations mais en
face il se passe un autre phénomène
c'est qu'on fait de plus en plus de
calculs alors c'est la métaphore de la
de la reine rouge de de lewis carroll
qui dit que dans cette course à la
puissance que ce soit pour les états
pour les entreprises si vous arrêtez de
courir eh ben vous reculé dans le
classement et vos concurrents vont être
devant donc on a besoin de plus en plus
de puissance informatique alors c'est
vrai dans les dessins animés c'est vrai
dans le monde bancaire et donc tout le
monde court plus vite que le progrès des
des ordinateurs donc du coup chaque
année on peut acheter des ordinateurs
plus performants mais il faut en acheter
plus et le résultat c'est qu'on fait ça
c'est à dire que maintenant on aligne
des ordinateurs de plus en plus alors ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle un centre de
calcul c'est on aligne beaucoup
d'ordinateurs pour faire beaucoup de
calcul est alors le problème c'est que
ce genre de dispositif c'est un peu
comme l'agriculture intensive massa tout
le monde est concentré les uns sur les
autres
ça produit énormément de chaleur et tous
ces ordinateurs il faut les refroidir
sinon il s'arrête de fonctionner et déjà
un des centres de calcul comme ça on en
construit de plus en plus donc comme je
vous disais bien sûr faux les refroidir
donc ça c'était l'intérieur et ça c'est
l'extérieur c'est les systèmes de
refroidissement alors si vous avez
l'occasion de vous balader en banlieue
parisienne perd peut-être que vous
trouverez ce type de bâtiment vous
verrez on les repère parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup de climatisation sur le sur le
toit et comment on construit de plus en
plus il ya une situation que les gens ne
perçoivent pas forcément mais qui
commence à sortir dans les médias et
puis surtout en france c'est que les
data center aujourd'hui les centres de
calcul dans les centres
de données on dit aussi qu'on sommes
déjà 3% de l'électricité mondiale
derrière vos facebook derrière vos
twitter etc
il ya des datacenter le cloud où on fait
croire que c'est quelque chose de
d'abstrait mais c'est quelque chose de
très concret et ça consomme 3 déjà 3% de
l'électricité mondiale et sa double tous
les cinq ans donc on est vraiment face à
une situation vous faut vraiment vous
rendre compte que derrière toute cette
informatique tout ce cloud il ya
beaucoup d'ordinateurs mais bien sûr on
va pas arrêter de faire du twitter on va
pas arrêter de faire du facebook on veut
pas rester d'utiliser google
il en faudra toujours plus mais il faut
trouver des moyens toujours alternatif
et intelligent pour pouvoir poursuivre
cette recette révolution informatique
alors c'est comme ça que j'ai un jour
j'ai eu une idée il ya un peu plus de
dix ans à l'époque où je travaillais
justement en informatique bancaire alors
j'avais un dada personnel qui était de
faire des ordinateurs celle silencieux
alors chacun sont chacun son dada mais
moi je sais moi c'était le j'en avais
j'en avais un certain nombre et puis il
y avait un côté pratique ce n'était pas
les éteindre le soir ce qui ne font
aucun bruit et puis dans mon travail on
exploitait ce type d'infrastructure qui
consommaient beaucoup de puissance de
calcul
mais là je me suis dit tiens avec
l'arrivée de la fibre optique et cetera
je pourrais tout à fait finalement faire
un système où je je vendrai la puissance
de calcul qui est chez moi et
silencieuse elle me dérange pas je
pourrais la réguler pour me chauffer
plus ou moins et je serai chauffer
gratuitement puis bon les banquiers il
paye assez bien pour pour l'époque en
tout cas pour pour utiliser toute cette
puissance de calcul donc on veut que je
pouvais même potentiellement me
rémunérer en vendant cette puissance de
calcul tout en ne chauffant
donc c'était une idée un peu un peu un
peu farfelu et en 2000 en 2010 j'ai
décidé de me lancer de créer carnot
consulting pour créer le radiateur
numérique qui est ce dispositif qui est
la fusion finalement entre un ordinateur
et
et un radiateur donc l'idée c'est
uniquement de profiter du besoin de
chauffage pour évacuer évacuer cette
chaleur et de réguler cette puissance de
calcul avec ce type de dispositif et
avec les réseaux qui existent
aujourd'hui dans les zones urbaines mais
de plus en plus dans le territoire ça
permet d'avoir un dispositif de
répartition du calcul plutôt que de les
concentrer comme de la gomme dans les
datacenters de les répartir
tranquillement dans la ville c'est un
peu comme l'agriculture bio finalement
donc vous avez l'agriculture intensive
et puis voilà il ya nous on a une
approche complètement différente de
répartir cette puissance dans des
bâtiments grâce à la connexion internet
donc c'est un modèle économique qui est
qu'on appelle bifaces vous serez
peut-être amenés à en rencontrer il y en
a avec les journaux gratuits où il faut
mettre en regard de deux de marché donc
d'un côté des gens qui veulent faire du
calcul
et puis de l'autre qui ont des gens qui
ont besoin de se chauffer ça permet
également d'avoir une économie à la fois
en énergie est également financière
puisque finalement on n'a pas besoin de
construire de data center pour déployer
cette puissance de calcul donc ça c'est
une première économie et on profite
finalement d'un besoin qui est un besoin
de chauffage pour disposer ces machines
donc ça nous permet d'avoir une
empreinte carbone tout à fait réduite
alors c'est tous ces éléments c'est des
choses qui bien sûr nécessite beaucoup
de travail au niveau de la répartition
informatique donc l'idée peut paraître
simple mais c'est le travail de toute
une équipe qui aujourd'hui travaillent
sur ce sujet depuis cinq ans et depuis
depuis maintenant un an on a à peu près
350 radiateur qui sont déployés
principalement en ile de france et qui
calcule pour bas des gens comme d'aidé
des banques également dans le monde du
dessin animé
et puis aussi dans la recherche
scientifique donc aujourd'hui on est
très fier parce que ça pouvait paraître
être une idée très farfelu au départ on
a même noué un partenariat avec un des
grands noms de l'informatique donc pour
nous c'est une grande fierté parce que
c'est une consécration
parce qu'aujourd'hui la vision de
l'informatique du futur parce qu'il va y
en avoir de plus en plus et c'est
certain il faut trouver les meilleurs
endroits et les endroits les plus
intelligents pour la mettre pour la
répartir vous allez avoir de plus en
plus d'objets connectés qui vont se
mettre à communiquer à donner à
récupérer des informations à les traiter
et c'est donc il va falloir des centres
de calcul il va falloir de la puissance
de calcul ou la m parfois c'est mieux de
la mettre dans un dans un centre de
calcul
nous on pense que c'est aussi très
intelligent de la mettre dans des
radiateurs et on est persuadé que
l'avenir ça sera un mix entre eux des
choses très concentré des choses très
très répartis pour revenir sur carnot
donc carnot il avait une vision donc ce
jeune homme il ay là il a révolutionné
le monde il avait 28 ans quand il a
écrit un livre qui a tout changé
il est mort à ces jeunes à 36 ans et
finalement cette machine que vous voyez
là on sait la lithographie d'un
processeur des premiers processeurs ça
aujourd'hui ça tient sur même pas une
tête d'épinglé donc et c'est une machine
et il faut réfléchir et à où les placer
c'est l'économie de demain vous êtes
aujourd'hui vous avez vous avez 20 ans
et vous allez vous allez vivre cette
révolution parce que je pense qu'on est
vraiment une époque qui va être
fulgurante à ce niveau là et il avait il
avait eu une phrase en conclusion de son
livre que j'ai trouvé assez incroyable
puis ça a été écrit avec quasiment deux
cents ans dix et l'économie du
combustible
c'est vraiment d'actualité c'est un
sujet mais ce n'est pas le forcément le
sait pas l'unique sujet il faut
réfléchir globalement à la machine ou
est-ce qu'on va la mettre
combien de fois il va falloir le
remplacer est ce qu'elle coûte cher
dépenser beaucoup d'argent sur une
machine pour pouvoir économiser un peu
de combustible est ce que ça vaut le
coup ou est ce que c'est le plus
intelligent de la m nous on a décidé de
le mettre dans des radiateurs
donc voilà l'avenir vous est ouvert et
et j'espère que vous serez vous inspirer
de sadi carnot
merci